hi so far in the story you've kept
expanding the world character by
character location by location and you
just told us about this a lot of places
you've introduced that we won't revisit
as readers but all the characters that
we haven't been inside the head of as of
yet that we will come to know in the
point of view you may be again as a
Vegas you want about this but we will be
exploring new characters that we haven't
been inside the head of us of yes my
plan is No
except of course for the prologues and
epilogues where as you know you usually
get in the viewpoint of a different
point of view character for one chapter
however that is subject to change as I
as I write the books I encounter
problems and sometimes I find that I
need a new point of view in order to
make it work I mean those of you who
follow discussions and conventions and
other interviews and some of the things
I post on my blog will know that with
the last book I had a particular trouble
with what I called the Marigny is not
with a number of characters arriving in
Mereen and I had a bunch of viewpoint
characters there already I had Quentyn
Martell turning up I had you know Tyrion
turning up I had Danny there and I kept
you know reworking these chapters and
rewriting from different point of view
and reordering who arrived first and
what happened first and what happened
second and I could never really make the
pieces fit and make the story flow the
way I wanted to until I finally said I'm
gonna give Cerberus an a viewpoint he's
he's the one I need there to make it
make it work make the post a nice tough
work you know make it Tyrion at Costa
Tyrion didn't even speak the language it
was very difficult to write to use
scenes where Tyrion was the viewpoint
character and he didn't know what the
[ __ ] anybody was saying
so but having Sorbara stand there
suddenly made those things work and you
know I may find that is necessary again
we'll we'll see but hopefully it won't
because I'd actually like to you know as
you say the story has been going further
and further out but it's it's past time
that the story turned that started
coming together and that's certainly my
overall plan and that's what I'm working
on right now but fewer viewpoint
characters not more but I'm not gonna
make a pledge in blood yes hi my name is
Ian Cheney I had a question actually
about the writing process for winds of
winter because well as we all know peace
for crows and dance with Dragon was
divided geographically and I was
wondering how challenging was it to
write win the winter with all this added
character and if you feel like you had
to shorten some story line well I'm not
finished it yet so so that you know who
knows what I'll discover by the time at
the end but I'm not planning on
shortening any storylines I am also not
planning on dividing it we're not going
to have another set of two parallel
books so though the books that did part
for those two volumes are or reuniting
there will be how do i phrase this
between the two books when you put them
together there's an access of viewpoint
characters so some of them may may not
survive the the action to come but you
know
we'll see about that hi um I was
wondering about a medical knowledge of
the maesters semesters because for
example jamie's hand when it's treated
they bring out their the guns the khyber
and things have a great knowledge about
human anatomy and so on and its history
fever standard for masters or is it an
exceptional game survives because they
suffer some gangrene very quickly well I
wanted you know I've made a deliberate
decision when the book began to have the
maesters and have Westeros in general
have better medical knowledge than to
realize the Middle Ages mostly because I
didn't want everybody dying at 26 and so
it is it is generally improved the
maesters have improved this the standard
of Hygiene and they understand certain
practices and they can do things better
also though they have magic which
doesn't always work because it's magic
and magic is unreliable but sometimes it
works and you know it brings people back
from the dead and things like that so
that also changes things and is a
adjunct to their general healing skills
it's odd though that some of the things
that they practiced in the Middle Ages
which were later rejected you know like
leeches and maggots are coming back
because it turns out that they knew more
than we thought they did and that uh you
know maggots actually can perform a
function hey George my name is axel gage
and first of all I wanted to say hi for
my friend Matt if it couldn't be here
today and my question is really a little
bit strange because I'm from a city not
far from here you may have heard of it
it's called Westeros yes I was asked
that this morning yeah it's purely
coincidence I'm afraid I had never heard
of your Swedish Westeros that's like a
related one um when you envision your
cities specifically like King's Landing
or white Harbor those kinds of places do
you think of any real-life cities that
you compare them to
like Stockholm maybe I don't know what
do you think those cities look like in
your mind why I've never actually been
to Stockholm before this so why I
couldn't really evoke that you know how
to the large extent these are based on
obviously not places I've been since I'm
another time traveler but they're based
on what I've read about actual medieval
cities medieval Paris medieval London
primarily the ones that are most
information is about in it is available
in English I wish I could read more of
the medieval history of other countries
but sad to say those books are seldom
translated into English and I have no
other languages not even Dothraki I am
high Valyrian and a little my name is
Martin appropriate it seems and more
based your question the dinosaur mice
are firing question you mentioned
Charles 2/12 and all the other swedish
kings and if I recall correctly
mentioned you have read scan the name in
history at college you know just a
general course no but you wrote a short
story that was later published as the
siege I think about a critical event in
Swedish history forgotten mostly about
the follows we are born in the liberal
thro the North right if you could tell
us something of why you wrote that and
what the story entailed because it's it
gets most people in here and we smear
Polly yes I wrote that my sophomore year
of college and Northwestern University
so I was you know eighteen years old or
something like that I was taking a
course in Scandinavian history a general
survey course and we were assigned to do
a term paper but in those days you know
I was I was taking courses in creative
writing I was trying to sell stories I
was sending out science fiction stories
of the magazines also writing non
science fiction stories and trying to
sell those and whenever I took a course
I would try to convince the professor to
let me write a short story instead of a
term paper so I went to that professor
in Scandinavian history and said they
didn't hey how about I do fiction
historical fiction and he said sure so I
wrote a a story about the render FEA
Borg in the Russia Swedish war of 1808
because it was a great historical
mystery that had come across during a
survey course and I'd read room Berg's
poem about it or the English translation
thereof and it seemed like a fascinating
subject in hey I got an A on the paper
and that was pretty good in 20 years
later I rewrote the story and I added a
time-traveling dwarf and so that's Omni
and got thousands of dollars so so it
worked out pretty well
the original story had no time-traveling
Dwarfs I was speaking I mean you took
it's kind of an even history course in
college and that was it was that just to
fill credits or you do something about
its kind of Naevia interested you I mean
here you are written well army of Sweden
what what interested me was the fact
that I knew nothing about it you know I
don't know what kind of history you're
taught here in Sweden but as a kid in
America growing up at least back when I
did in the 50s and 60s you know you get
American history and then you get a
course called Western civilization and
it's like you get them over and over
again you know you start in grade school
and you and you get you know British
colonists Jamestown Plymouth Rock
American Revolution George Washington
Andrew Jackson who here comes the Civil
War Abraham Lincoln etc and then you get
in in the next year then you get the
world history you know the the the
Egyptians and and the Greeks and then
the Romans and Battle of Marathon and
memorizing the dates and then you go
forward and you get to you know you get
the Crusades and the Middle Ages well
the Roman Empire and the Dark Ages and
the Middle Ages and all of that stuff
and you follow England mostly and then
you go on to like high school and you
get the same subjects but just in more
detail you know then they tell you all
the stuff they taught you in grade
school is not actual
true you know George Washington didn't
chop down the cherry tree and he wasn't
standing up when they crossed the
Trenton in the boat and all that stuff
so you first you get the myths and then
you get a little more realistic and then
you reach college and you get the same
subjects taught over in what in college
you also have electives where you can
take in the history with my minor so I
said I don't want to hear any more about
the Romans or the Greeks or the Battle
of Marathon or the Battle of Hastings I
know all that [ __ ] I've been over it
like four times already what's this
stuff about Scandinavian I know nothing
about them you know I know that I saw
the Vikings once and that seems sort of
interesting so I'll study that I also
took courses in in Chinese history and
you know other other exotic courses that
covered histories that I had never
previously studied and of course I found
it all fascinating hi my name is Emma
I'm wondering I like reading you're like
not a blog dog and you you have so many
like interesting and fun projects going
on and I'm wondering like like how many
projects do you have and where do you
find the time to rest do you rest I have
a lot of projects I maybe too many
projects I don't know I get every time I
announce a new when I get angry fans
hooray why you're doing something else
you should be writing winds of winter I
have an overall deal with HBO which
means that they pay me vast sums of
money to entirely aside from the vast
sums of money they're paying me for Game
of Thrones they pay me other vast sums
of money to invent new shows for them so
um I invent ideas and sometimes they say
now have we don't like that but other
times they say oh that's good and then
we go out and we develop the idea and we
hire writer and we write a pilot so you
know and if they like the pilot they
make the pilot and if they like what
they make then you have a new show on
the air and I
like three projects like that that I've
invented as part of my overall deal that
are in various stages of development one
of them actually become television shows
I got no clue you know it's it's a
crapshoot I mean in the 1990s I spent
five years in development working for
Columbia Pictures and developing pilots
for ABC and the Fox Network and I wrote
something I thought were good scripts
good shows but not oh never went all the
way it's you know many pilots are made
and things are done I've got my wild
card series which I've been editing for
you know decades now it goes back longer
than Ice and Fire it's still ongoing and
other things come my way you know us and
they seem like fun so I work on them but
one thing that almost all of these other
projects have in common is that I'm not
doing the writing or I'm doing a little
bit of the writing but somebody else is
doing most of the writing they may be
based on an old script that I wrote a
long time ago there maybe based on a
short story for example we are
developing the skin trade my novella
that I published nightly was 1987 as a
potential television series I wrote a
novella but other people are writing the
the pilot script and so if it goes
forward this is the same trick of course
I used with Elio and Linda is bring
other people with broad and get them to
do most of the work and you know that
that works works very well although I
wound up somehow you turned that on me
and I wound up doing a hell of a lot of
work anyway so
you know I like making stuff up what can
I say I've been telling stories since I
was a kid and and these new projects are
exciting I'd hate to ever think I was
just like doing one thing over and over
again and you know I hope that some of
you guys and some of the other readers
out there enjoy the other projects as
well as I know you love Westeros and you
love Ice and Fire
and I do too but I also love my other
children and I realize didn't I was
popular I hope I never arrived I mean I
knew Frank Herbert a little not he
wasn't a close friend or anything but I
met him a little in the last few years
of his life and Frank had actually kind
of come to hate Doon by the end because
that was all anybody wanted from him and
he really wanted to write he had other
novels he wanted to write other worlds
and characters he wanted to create and
his publishers and his fans were just
saying we don't care about that just
give us another dune novel okay thanks
for that one give us another novel okay
that was good give us another dune novel
and I hope I never wind up in that
situation which me I don't have to
because you know I'm doing well enough
so that when I finish ice and fire I can
write it pretty much anything I want and
if it only sells three thousand copies I
won't give a crap what I hope it won't
and actually I don't think even when I
finished ice and fire I this story will
be finished but I don't think I'll ever
be finished with the world obviously I
have to finish my sidebars and publish
those as the history of the Targaryen
dynasty fire and blood and then I have
more Dunkin egg stories to write I've
only got maybe a third of the way
through their careers and and and I who
knows maybe I'll write a whole series of
things set in et
exploring some of the history that I put
there so I that's the great thing about
creating a world is you have a world to
play and not just a particular set of
characters